so here's the thing i think apple may be
a little bit confused what to do with a
13-inch macbook pro having said that
though this m2 chip is very impressive
what's up guys it's me bobby and we are
back talking about the all-new 13-inch
macbook pro m2 version the pro and the
air m2 were announced at wwdc a few
weeks ago we got the pro first the air
will be coming in shortly we'll be doing
a review on that as well but i'll give
you my first impressions run through
some tests and all those great things so
here's what's going to happen in this
video we're not going to talk about
geekbench scores or anything like that
we're going to talk about real world
usage because that to me is the most
important scores are one thing
but using in the real world
video editing photo editing browsing the
web also i want to tell you how i use my
laptop because to see if it fits with
your usage because you might watch this
video and go look i don't use my laptop
that way this might not apply to me or
hey i do use the things or the apps that
bob uses so
i'll listen to them okay here's what i
do i browse the web do you browse the
web i'm sure you do
i watch youtube videos i'm actually
making a video for youtube right now and
hopefully you're watching it and liking
it and subscribing to the channel as
well um i
answer emails we have to do that
nowadays right yes i do whatsapp i do
telegram i use my photos app i do all
those things all those
things we do every day
and then i do photo editing and video
editing now i use lightroom cc and then
i use photoshop i shoot with a variety
of different cameras uh as you can see
behind me there's a lot of gear on those
shelves i use pretty much all of it and
anywhere from medium format to 100
megapixels all the way down to the
basics then i edit video i use final cut
pro primarily and i am going to be
editing various different footage 8k
footage from the nikon z9 that i'm
actually recording with right now but
it's in 4k uh prores 422 raw hq that i
recorded with the atomos ninja 5
recently for a review i'll be dumping
that in here as well to test it out to
see how it performs and then variety of
things how it works in photoshop what
it's like to zoom in on images or use
the healing brush or things like that
we're gonna see some of those tasks at
hand here in the 13-inch macbook pro and
see how it performs now again i'm using
this without a charger to it i'm using
it on battery only because recently
apple's been very good with this they
did they were fantastic with the 16 inch
macbook pro m1 max version i have here
on my desk which is powering my whole
setup i got a zoom f6 that is plugged
into that for my audio recording which
you see here in here right now i'm also
using my friends iso 27-inch 2k monitor
for editing that's plugged into the
macbook pro as well
so
unfortunately this 13-inch pro like its
predecessors only has two ports one you
have to use for power if you want to
charge it and the other four whatever it
may be
possibly another hub because what are
you gonna do with two usbc thunderbolt 3
ports or thunderbolt 4 ports what are
you going to do with it not much a pro
machine should have more ports apple we
have peripherals
it needs to be included but they haven't
changed this body design since i think
2016 so
that is a conversation for another day
anyway
let's get down to talking about this
laptop what it's got inside and we'll
get into the review okay in terms of
specs space grays you're seeing right
here this is a one terabyte 16 gigabytes
unified memory inside of this uh that's
how it's working on this so this is uh
not the top end because i think you can
max it out at 24 gigabytes of unified
memory and of course increase the
storage but this is a very healthy spec
m2 13 inch macbook pro that i think a
lot of you will probably pick up if
you're going to get one
so
having said that how does it perform
what are the specs like what's it like
for the brightness of the display let's
get down to it if you have not seen a
review of a macbook pro 13-inch in the
last uh four years well let me refresh
your memory the display is not a liquid
retina hdr display it is a retina
display it goes up to about 500 nits and
that's about it your webcam on this is a
720p it's not even 1080p on this so if
you're looking for that upgraded webcam
you got to go for the macbook air i've
got the touch bar on this which i like
personally i like the touch bar some
people hate the touch bar they want
they want physical keys they want to
feel more traditional to me i'm like hey
screw that i like the touch bar you got
all these functions here it changes
depending on the
on the program that you're using it just
is beautiful i don't know why apple got
rid of it i think they listened to too
many of the naysayers but apple bring
back the touch bar you can enhance it a
little bit maybe a little brighter
display or whatever the case may be but
i like the touch bar and uh the
processor the m2 processor like i you
saw you heard right there prores prores
raw does handle 8k better as well and
you will see in some of the tests that i
did recorded with obs how it performs
and do take in mind that obs is a little
bit taxing on the system as it is so if
it's handling it pretty well with obs on
it will handle it even better with obs
off that's how i can record the screen
so you can actually see how it works
um but let's talk about day-to-day
battery life this claims 20 hours i've
been getting anywhere from
15 to 16 to 17 hours depending on my
brightness of the display i maxed out
the brightness on this macbook pro 13
inch so i want to you know take
advantage of the 500 nits that this
produces which isn't as much as other
laptops but it's good enough for daily
use outside of that i'm pretty much
wireless free for the most part i mean a
size like this you don't want to plug
into the wall all the time something
like a 16 inch you're gonna have it
plugged in more so because you're gonna
be connecting it and probably using it
as sort of a desktop replacement
this is gonna be on the go with you uh
so battery life has been very stellar
for me in that regard no issues at all
um the fan does not kick on pretty much
unless you're doing
rendering
uh video and that's a lot and you'll see
that in just a bit with the pro res uh
raw it does kick on quite a bit because
it is you know rendering a what is it
about a 12 minute file there abouts 90
some gigabytes it's quite hefty and it
does the fan does kick on on that and
but it doesn't i mean you're going to
feel the heat a little bit underneath it
but it's only on one side but it's not
hot to the touch it's just warm but it
still performs beautifully very
impressive this m2 chip imagine what
that m2 pro or m2 max is going to be
like
man i just got this laptop a few months
ago and that'll be outdated by the end
of the year probably if we know how
apple works but hopefully they take a
breather and say guys enjoy the m1 max
and the m1 pro a little bit more before
we spoil the market with the m2 prone m2
max anyway getting back to this bad boy
here really quickly um
otherwise it's great there's no hiccups
no stuttering nuts nothing whatsoever so
what we're gonna do right now is i'm
going to load up some footage here from
as uh the footage the pro res raw 422 hq
4k footage into final cut pro we're
gonna render that see how that goes then
we're also going to do 8k 30 uh with a
32 bit raw wav file from my
zoom f6 we're going to synchronize those
together that's about a 39 second file
there and then we'll render that to see
how that goes so with that let's go down
to testing out
this macbook pro 13-inch m2
with two ports
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
[Music]
okay
so as we saw from the test it is not too
bad at all so this 11 minute and 25
second file which was prores 422 raw hq
4k
that is a long name for a file
um actually did pretty well uh the
rendering time took four minutes and 10
seconds that's on battery power only and
that's with obs running in the
background the fan did kick on pretty
loud this is the first time i heard this
fan really wind up almost like a mini
turbine but it was warm to the touch but
not hot to the touch so if you are going
to do a very large file in that capacity
with that prores hq
and you're gonna do let's say
20 minutes or so plug this bad boy in
make sure it's on a cool surface just so
it doesn't uh you know cook your table
sort of speaks i'm joking it's not that
hot but uh yeah just be mindful of that
and then we uh rendered the ak-30 file
from the nikon z9 then i synchronized it
with my 32-bit wav file from the zoom f6
and that was a 39 second clip that took
about 40 seconds to render that entire
thing so that is not bad at all so if we
had a larger would be interesting to see
how it handles i would guess some
throttling will come into play
especially with the heat going out of
this processor especially when it is
processed or you know rendering high
resolution files like that so that's
something to take note of but again if
you plug in and i think that should
override that to some extent and of
course if you just work with your power
management systems settings it should be
okay but overall very impressive for an
m2 chip and it's going it just again it
reminds you what's going to happen in
the near future where this m1 max that
we just got well it's not going to be
outdated it'll still work great
but the m2 will just probably blow
through everything and then some all
right so for a lot of you out there who
are looking for a laptop for day-to-day
usage you're not going to be a heavy
video editing or photo editing person
you're just going to be browsing the web
you'll be able to do some of this stuff
but not a lot of it i think the 13-inch
pro will be great for you but the
question remains should you go for the
air now the air doesn't have a fan
system inside of it this has one fan
will that make a difference i don't know
well apple throttle the air so the pro
does get a little bit of the edge in
terms of power and performance remains
to be seen but the air does come with
fast charging magsafe
upgraded webcam so you are getting some
things in there that the pro is not
getting
so i mean we'll do a test when it comes
in we'll compare them both and we'll let
you guys know but i would say
first impressions
this is very good
but
you got a 14-inch macbook pro that is
right above it that is performing better
in some ways and in some ways right on
par and then you got the air right
behind it so it's going to be a very
tough decision and i think apple needs
to decide what to do with a 13-inch pro
a pro machine should have more than two
pro ports and it should
be significantly better than an air in
my personal opinion i may be wrong on
this but that's what i feel and i feel
they haven't decided what to do with
this they should just probably just call
it a 13 inch macbook and leave it at
that let the pro start at the 14 inch i
think that might be a better way to go
about it but
nobody's asking me for my opinion i'm
just giving it to you guys anyway those
are my thoughts on the 13 inch macbook
pro m2 version let me know your thoughts
in the comments section below do you
agree with me do you disagree with me
any thoughts you have let me know i'll
try to answer those for you we will be
doing a follow-up review with the air
when it comes out and comparing it to
this so watch out for that hit that
notification bell subscribe to the
channel as well and like this video take
care stay safe guys and i'll chat to you
soon bye
you